how would your boss feel about doing
business with them
an official sex offender if he became
president again
well who becomes president of course is
a decision for voters in the United
States and
the relationship between the two
countries is is really important
um but in terms of the verdict that we
saw
yesterday I think the one thing
to resist here is the Temptation
sometimes especially in political
discussions to immediately sort of
analyze this in terms of what we'll do
with his chances will it reinforce
people you've got to remember there's a
victim here and there are other victims
who are probably watching this program
and what they don't want is when you get
a verdict like that politicians or
journalists or this kind of discussion
to descend into you know electoral
chances one way or the other and I've
seen some of that over the last 24 hours
and I think we've got to remember uh
there are victims of sexual assault and
worse who are watching this who've been
scared to come forward and they'll be
watching Pretty closely what happens and
what the reaction to you I get that
totally um Mr McFadden but also they
might also be thinking we wouldn't want
our leader to be talking to somebody who
thinks it's okay to behave in that
fashion uh well of course as I said who
becomes president is a decision for
voters in the United States the
relationship between the UK and the
United States is one of the strongest
and deepest in the world it's not just
based on who's President and who's prime
minister there's there's history there's
interests there's values that runs right
through it and I don't think
anything is going to change that that
sort of depth of that relationship would
you do a deal with the lib Dems in order
to get in power do you know I find this
discussion so presumptuous we're a year
out from the election I can tell you
what our aim is but
I don't want to speculate what a result
is going to be we're aiming for a
majority that's what we hope for that's
what we've achieved in the past but all
this you know if spots and maybes
uh I think the voters watching this will
be saying hang on you know listen if I
haven't done that road they'd be saying
why are they talking about that when
interest rates are probably going to go
up tomorrow I'm still struggling to make
ends meet
um I think winning trust in those issues
is more important yeah I mean here's me
sitting here wondering why you're
dismissing my questions is it because
um you are contemplating doing a deal
with the lib Dems no it's it's not
because of that it's because I do think
that kind of discussion of what happens
after is really presumptuous in fact you
could even call it arrogant and I don't
think politicians should be arrogant I
think they should approach the voters
you never met an arrogant politician
I've met a few but I think I think that
uh they should approach the voters with
humility because uh you know we want to
get a majority government and I'll tell
you more if we did get a majority
government
if you know if yeah you know I would be
one of the people the day after that
saying this is such a precious and
fragile thing the trust of the people I
mean I remember working for Tony Blair
many years ago when we had a majority of
179 I remember after the 1997 election
and people would come in and see him and
say oh you're guaranteed to get elected
next time you can do this you can do
that he always dismissed that and said
you've got no idea how tough it is to
get a majority uh how precious it is uh
and how you've got to treat that with
great care and I think he was right
about that so I do hope for a majority
but I hope for more than one majority
because I think after the last 13 years
it's going to take a long time to turn
the country around
um so you're saying not just this next
election wherever it might come but the
one after that well uh you know you've
got to be ambitious quite ambitious it
tastes ambitious but I'm conscious how
tough that is and my job along with my
boss Rachel Reeves is to make sure that
we pass the essential Trust of being
trusted with the public finances the
financial stability is there that are
Manifesto is properly costed and funded
so when the Tories bring out these uh
silly dossiers about Taxation and
borrowing that they're treated with a
tourism that they deserve from the
public what is it about the libderms
that you don't agree with
look you know I've gone through the
policy program a b and c I'm not
interested in doing that we'll put a
good policy program forward uh for the
public at the next election uh it'll be
both realistic and ambitious uh and I
think that's a good combination so that
we offer people change but we also are
honest with them about the the time it
will take and the economic circumstances
that are likely to be inherited by
anyone who wins at the next election
you were um I mean you've literally
smashed them
um at the local elections a thousand
seats lost more than a thousand seats
lost
um but you still don't wouldn't get if
that was converted to the general
election you still wouldn't have an
overall majority would you well we've
got is it that you have to do well we've
you know we've had great results last
week when I think of the places we won
and swimmed and in stalk and Plymouth
and Medway and many others and I'll pay
tribute to you know all the councilors
who were elected all the labor
campaigners and the voters who supported
us uh and that's given us a good
platform and it's a good platform to aim
for the majority but we know there's
still work to do there's always work to
do that's why I do think we should
approach this with some humility
I think it's the right way to go so that
we say to the voters you've given us a a
big boost last week through these local
elections which were only in part of the
country they weren't in Scotland they
weren't in Wales they weren't in London
uh you've given us a big boost we're
going to now use that to work even
harder than before to earn your trust so
that when the next election comes we get
a majority labor government okay
um a couple of other things before I let
you go um I won't use the acronym but
workers who only work Tuesday Wednesday
and Thursday apparently that makes up an
acronym let's not talk about it I can't
think what yeah apparently there's a
boss at AO world where he says he's
Banning a hybrid work and people should
be back in the office now and if you're
working from home you might as well be
working from somewhere in Europe or in
India or in Pakistan and you're at the
door well there's two things there I
don't think you should ban it uh I think
you know this can suit a lot of people
it can open up employment opportunities
for people who aren't there and I think
um some jobs in some circumstances can
be done very well in that kind of hybrid
way where you might be in the office or
not personally I prefer to be in the
office I'm not a great fan of these Zoom
calls and all the rest of it but is that
kind of the technology is too tricky
well you know uh I just I prefer the
face-to-face like this okay
um so there's that but in terms of uh
well you could be working abroad or you
could be working anywhere all these
Technologies create change we we went
through a huge change in how goods were
produced where globalization meant their
physical Goods could be produced
elsewhere in the world and so on
technology today it's not just about one
aspect of it might mean uh big
implications for service Industries in a
way that previous change meant for
manufacturing Industries so I think
everyone in politics should be curious
about these things but I don't think we
should be banning working from home very
briefly Before I Let You Go these this
barge the first of many barges has just
arrived does labor support migrants
being kept on those barges look I think
you you've got to consult properly with
Luke authorities in local communities
about this that's one of the Amendments
that we put forward to the immigration
bill when it went through Parliament is
going into the starting in the Lords
today and I'm sure that's the kind of
amendment that labor so in theory you
support it well we've got to with all
this temporary accommodation I've got uh
people in Wolverhampton uh staying in
hotels and I think the the problem with
some of this is it's done without proper
consultation with the local authorities
you've got to find temporary
accommodation but it's got to be done
with some degree of dialogue and
consultation with the local authorities
otherwise the government is ending up
just dumping people around the country I
know you've got a busy day ahead so I
must let you go it's always a pleasure
thank you very much and if you're
joining us thank you